所以，今天我要讲的是，嗯，智能效率，对吧？以及我们如何最大化它。我先从三张图表开始。
我想谈谈我们行业目前的位置，以及我认为我们应该走向何方。嗯，我们现在在哪里，对吧？Chat GPT出来了，LLM热潮发生了。智能水平随时间飙升。我们都看到了这一点，对吧？我们都看到了
这些基准。智能水平只在增长，呈指数级增长，对吧？另外，随着这一点，我们看到了代币数量激增，随时间推移，行业出现了代币上限，整个行业真的已经
将LLM全面采用到生产流程中，导致了这种情况，对吧？但另外，我认为我们看到的是，这些模型变得更聪明了，但它们的聪明并没有变得更高效，
对吧？你付更多的钱，我们看到这里最先进的，对吧？你知道，这是传说。这可能是去年的模型。你为智能付出的钱实际上正在产生
收益递减，对吧？这并不是世界被灌输的概念，对吧？我们被告知LLM可以用单位经济价格购买智能。但我们实际上支付的是代币，对吧？这是不对的，对吧？
这是我们作为技术人员都知道的，我们知道智能不等于代币。然而人们试图购买这个，但实际上买的是那个，对吧？这里存在根本性的差异，我认为这实际上会
反过来咬LLM供应商一口，对吧？我们在某种程度上看到了这种对数曲线，而人们想要更线性的曲线，对吧？嗯，有些数据支持这一点。我在Ramp工作，就像Darko说的。嗯，所以我们看到了很多
数据中的这种情况。嗯，一些统计数据显示，自2025年1月以来，月度代币支出增长了13倍。我们还看到科技领域发生了一些政治性事件，对吧？我们看到了Uber，我们看到了
Meta在限制这种代币滥用，确保这种指数增长不会真的继续下去，因为它影响到了利润。我们最近也做了一个Ramp版的sweet bench，我们看到了
这种更像对数曲线的趋势，智能实际上随时间变得更不高效，而不是更高效。我个人一直在研究的是，如何确保这个图更线性
而不是更对数化，对吧？我发现，上下文似乎是关键，为了给模型提供更多上下文，它们往往会变得更高效，需要更少的工作就能完成
相同的过程。我想给出一些数学基础。嗯，我对LLM和整个AI，以及生成过程的理解是，它们实际上是熵减机器，对吧？所以熵
是状态的混乱程度。如果你想想LLM，它们做的是获取高熵状态，嗯，它们获取PDF、从网络获取信息、从非常分散的领域获取信息，以及提示词，然后
嗯，把它们组织成用户要求的东西，对吧？它们从根本上降低了状态的熵。我认为从这种思考方式中，我们实际上可以推导出方程，显示将上下文引入领域如何使LLM和
整个AI更高效。所以有两种基本的熵观点。有一种信息论的熵观点，即香农熵定义，它说在观察后，状态的熵会从根本上减少。
我认为这是相当明显的，对吧？你有一个混乱的系统，你去测量它，你就多理解一点，所以系统的混乱程度，至少在我们的局部表示中，是减少了，
对吧？另外，热力学观点认为，系统中可以减少的熵量受限于你投入的功，并且是上界。结合这两个方程，我们可以看到系统熵变有一个上界，
这个上界既来自你投入的功，也来自我们已经拥有的关于系统的信息。我向人们解释的方式是，比如说，你在打扫房间，对吧？你得知道脏衣服在哪里，
然后投入工作把它们放到正确的地方，对吧？所以要把一个混乱的系统变成一个不那么混乱的系统，你必须同时具备这两者。我认为现代LLM确实专注于我们能投入多少功，
对吧？思维链、推理，我们看到你投入的功越多，就能减少系统的熵。我们看到了。我们知道这不是线性的，但这是真的。但人们不一定关注信息部分，
对吧？我将举三个例子来说明，如何向系统提供上下文、记忆、信息，无论你怎么称呼它，特别是在潜在空间中，可以使LLM更节能或更
智能高效，好吗？为了提供一些背景，当前在这个领域提供上下文的方法像是RAG或记忆，但我们都知道这些有问题，对吧？它们扩展性不好，通常用于大海捞针
或语义搜索任务，并且真的难以应对多跳推理查询，对吧？多跳推理，如果你不知道的话，就是，你知道，把一堆事实放在一起，然后构建
一个逻辑答案。它们也都在代币空间中发生，这从根本上对模型来说受限，而不是在潜在空间中，对吧？嗯，我将讨论潜在空间中的三个例子，我认为它们是高效的方式，嗯，
向底层模型传递上下文，提升智能效率。这涉及到多智能体系统。
粉笔快用完了。好，在上下文窗口里，
以及作为输入，对吧？这些就是我过去几个月研究的三个领域，然后我会逐一解释。先从多智能体系统开始。
我会给出多智能体系统的模型，然后解释如何改进以及改进后看到的结果。多智能体系统，我们可以抽象地说，有一个监管智能体，然后它可以生成工作智能体。
我敢肯定大家都了解这类事情，对吧？他们都会完成任务，但假设这是时间轴。问题在于这极其低效。使用的token数量真的非常惊人，在当前的算力经济下，token消耗过大难以持续，我们需要解决这个问题。
它消耗的token数量真的非常惊人，在当前的算力经济下，token消耗过大难以持续，我们需要解决这个问题。另外，监管智能体在工作的同时，
它在生成上下文，探索系统。我们还会看到工作智能体也在生成自己的上下文，并且这些上下文不共享到全局状态，对吧？一个工作智能体在这里发现的上下文可能已经在那里发现了，现在我们却在做额外的工作，变得非常低效。
导致额外工作，效率低下。因此，我做的部分研究是，假设我们共享上下文，维护一个全局上下文状态，我把它实现为智能体间共享的全局知识库缓存。当我们生成一个新的智能体时，获取它的任务，从知识库缓存中筛选出所需信息。我们基本上用压缩算法做到这一点，然后以初始化的知识库缓存来生成工作智能体，这缓存基本上包含了系统中对工作智能体重要的上下文。
当我们生成新智能体并获取其任务时，从知识库缓存中筛选所需信息。我们用压缩算法实现，然后以这个初始化的知识库缓存来生成工作智能体，其中包含了系统中对工作智能体重要的上下文。
这些上下文对工作智能体很重要。在多种任务上将这个系统与无上下文共享的系统对比，我们看到总共减少了42%到57%的工作智能体token使用量，
并且总token使用量减少了21%到31%，同时保持了相同的准确率，对吧？因此，仅通过共享上下文，将信息引入全局系统，它们就变得高效得多。另外，
我还做了一些关于上下文学习的工作，大家都看到了DeepSeek发布的稀疏注意力模型，希望我们都看到了。我们看到稀疏注意力确实风靡业界，这很合理，
对吧？我们需要比密集注意力更高效的方法。但我想研究稀疏注意力的方式是将其建模为重排序器模型，对吧？基本上，如果你思考稀疏注意力，它是在看一个token，
这个token说：“我需要过去token的哪些信息来生成下一个token？”这与RAG中的重排序器工作方式非常相似。所以我想说：“好的，如果这能建模成
重排序系统，那将是证据表明更高效的模型至少部分是因为在其自身的token空间或潜在空间上准确的上下文检索。因此，我们做的是取了DeepSeek模型中的lightning indexer生成的查询和键，
我们取了DeepSeek模型中闪电索引器生成的查询和键，然后在一个多跳问答数据集上计算文档分数，看它是否能准确找到问题的正确文档。
我写出我们怎么做的公式。如果你们有任何问题，可以会后问我，因为我讲得比较快。但基本上，我们计算了归一化查询与键之间的ReLU分数，
对于这些查询，我们有一个包含大量文档和基于这些文档的多选题的数据集。查询来自多选题数据集中的问题，我们使用文档本身的归一化键。
我们使用文档的归一化键。然后，我们可以为每个文档计算一个分数，就是每个头这些分数乘以权重后求和，然后取文档中所有token的平均值。
我们发现，使用这种相当简单的评分方法，从稀疏注意力机制中，我们实际上匹配或超越了当前最先进的重排序模型，显示这本质上镜像了重排序器，本质上就是这样。
它本质上是对上下文窗口的上下文检索。这里我想重申，还有两分钟时间，但我想重申这两个例子都是对系统进行基本信息注入的例子，
上下文检索，使整个系统更高效，对吧？稀疏注意力比密集注意力高效得多。在多智能体系统中，我们展示了在获得相同结果时平均token使用量大幅减少。
为了获得相同的结果。最后我要谈的是我与斯坦福SNAP实验室做的一些工作，旨在减少输入中实际需要的token数量，而不是输出，
同时保持结果。我们有一个想法，做LLM系统时，为什么做RAG必须把整个文档放入上下文窗口？相反，如果我们把记忆或上下文注入当作一种模态，就像处理文本、图像、视频一样，它本身就是一种完整的模态，那会怎样？
把注入视为一种模态，就像文本、图像、视频一样，它本身就是一个完整模态，那会怎样？所以我们构建了一个记忆模块，这是我们的名称，我们输入文档以及查询。
这就像是一个多跳推理数据集。我们构建了一个架构，输入这些数据，产生16个潜在表示，然后直接注入到冻结的大型语言模型中。这里我们用的是Qwen。
8B模型。我们的理论是，如果我们能注入16个潜在空间表示，这些表示往往能捕捉文档中与查询相关的必要信息，那么模型会表现如何呢？直接注入到冻结的LLM中。
我们发现，在TriviaQA数据集上，我们的方法实际上击败了RAG-50，也就是将最相关的50个文档直接注入上下文窗口的token空间的方法，而且优势相当明显。所以使用这种方法，我们能...
注入16个潜在空间表示，在TriviaQA数据集上得到63%的精确匹配，而RAG-50只有55%。而且，这实际上在输入中使用的token表示少了372倍。所以，这...
它表现更好，对吧？它更智能高效，同时使用的token少372倍。所以，仅仅通过在潜在空间中引入正确的上下文，它就变得极其高效。好，我希望我已经说服你们，潜在...
在LLM中，上下文的潜在空间表示和上下文检索是极其重要的。我想给你们留下我认为是模型能准确引入上下文的圣杯。我认为它应该具有低...
延迟，以便在推理时使用。我认为它应该能扩展到大型语料库，而且对基础LLM应该几乎没有切换成本，这样当下一个模型出现时，你可以引入最...
先进的推理模型，同时仍保持这种上下文中断进入全局系统。这些都是我正在探索的研究课题，以便我们能在大型AI工具系统中引入它们，这些系统...
我们在Ramp使用的系统，比如Inspect，在那里我们实际上生成了比以往更多的上下文。谢谢。